[MUSIC PLAYING]
FARNOOSH BROCK: Imagine this--
what if we could do
business without selling?
What if we could
have all the results
we want in our professional
careers or businesses
without ever having to sell?
Hi, I'm Farnoosh Brock.
And it is a privilege to be
here at Google with you today,
talking about my book,
"The Serving Mindset."
We're going to
talk about how you
can change your conversations
from selling to serving,
to achieve anything you want.
I come from an academic family.
I studied electrical
engineering in college.
I wrote a master's thesis on
spread spectrum code division
multiple access for
wireless communications.
I tell you that to
show you how far I
was from the world of selling.
And I liked it that way.
All my life, the way I
had been experiencing
traditional selling--
the way people had
pitched their agenda
to me-- had really
turned me off of selling.
And so when I went to
the corporate world
to start my career, I wanted to
build a nice protective shell
around myself to avoid selling.
And to keep my attitude and
distance around selling.
And I was lucky.
My technical roles
allowed me to do that.
There were those
occasions when I
had to sell myself to
my management-- which
I did very poorly.
But otherwise, I was
able to make a living,
and still keep my
distance from selling.
Until 2011, when I
decided to quit my job,
and start my business.
And that is when my nice
protective shell cracked open.
I couldn't keep that
distance or attitude
around selling because
I was in business now.
And yet, how could I go out
there and be selling when
I couldn't stand being sold to?
That's when I felt this
was a real dilemma.
And yet even then,
deep down, I felt
there was a way I
could stay in business
and maybe even thrive
in my business,
and be true to my
character and my values.
And like who I was by
the end of the day.
So that curiosity led me
down a path of research,
which later became the
foundation of the book,
"The Serving Mindset."
In that research, I found--
much to my relief--
that I am far from
the only one having
this dilemma around selling.
Smart, talented, highly
educated professionals
and entrepreneurs, like us,
struggle with this every day.
Why?
Because nobody likes
to be sold to, not even
your most eager
buyer in the world.
And yet, we feel
we have to sell.
Because we need to
create the results
that we want in our
careers and our businesses.
And so from that
perspective, selling
becomes the necessary
evil in the equation.
And I've seen two
paths emerge from that.
One is for those of
us who feel, well,
what's a little compromise
around my values?
At least I'm being responsible.
I am doing what I need
to do to get my job done.
Even as I feel
conflicted about it,
even as I apologize for
the selling I'm doing--
I do what needs to be done.
There is the other
path for those of us
who feel I can't stand selling.
I am not a salesperson.
So then we need to build
that protective shell,
and find a line of
work that allows
us to keep that distance.
Because at least, at
the end of the day,
you don't have to do the
nauseating work of selling.
You're being true
to who you are.
Now, neither of those
two paths serves us.
Because in both of them,
we compromise something.
And I found, maybe we don't
have to do the compromise.
Do we really have to
compromise between our values
and our profits?
Or our characters
and our bottom line?
I found with the
serving mindset,
you don't have to do
that because I remove
selling from the equation.
We're not going
to talk about how
to sell more compassionately,
or more gently, or with empathy.
No.
We are going to remove
selling from the equation.
And yet, still achieve
the results that we want.
Now before I go further, let
me define selling and serving
so that we are on the same page.
The way I define
serving is this--
well, no, let me
start with selling.
Selling is when you have your
own highest agenda at heart.
You have your
agenda, your goals,
and you're going after them.
When you sell, you win.
When you don't sell, you lose.
Serving is when you
have your prospect,
your would be customer or
client's highest interest
at heart, regardless
of outcome for you.
When you serve,
you can only win.
When you serve, if they buy
from you right away, you win.
If they don't buy from you, but
buy from you down the road--
sometimes months and
years down the road--
because of how you treated
them, you still win.
Sometimes your prospect
never buys from you,
but they refer you.
They endorse you.
They speak highly of you because
of the way you served them.
So that's the way I define
selling and serving.
Now, I said earlier--
we are going to remove
selling from the equation.
Let's see how we can do
that, and get away with it,
so to speak.
So to do that, we start
by looking at our mindset.
Our mindset is our
perspective onto the world.
It's our version of reality.
Your mindset is a
collection of beliefs
that you have accumulated
over the course
of your life, your upbringing,
your relationships,
your education.
And it's your truth on
certain subject matters.
Now having lived
life, you may also
know that after some
transformative experiences
you may emerge with
a shift in mindset.
A shift in perspective.
So your mindset
isn't set in stone.
What we want to
explore together today
is that mindset around selling.
Even if you've never
thought about it,
you have a current
mindset around selling.
What I want to explore with you
is, is that mindset accurate?
Is it true?
And is it helping you do your
greatest work in this world,
and serve yourself and those
that you hope to impact?
So we're going to do that by
exploring the three guiding
principles of the
serving mindset.
The first principle says,
stop selling, start serving.
In this principle,
you'll rewire your brain.
And you'll remove selling
from your inner dialogue,
from your inner voice.
So your inner dialogue
becomes I am not
having sales conversations.
I am having serving
conversations.
I am not in a sales role.
I am in a serving role.
I do not need a
selling strategy--
thank you very much--
I need a serving strategy.
When you do this--
when you start to remove selling
from your inner dialogue,
you feel a sense
of ease and calm.
I see this when I
work with my clients.
They immediately
feel a sense of ease
because instinctively,
you are wired to help,
to be of genuine
help and service.
You feel you have to do more,
hence the pressure of selling.
But instinctively,
you are wired to help.
So when you give yourself
permission to remove the words
selling from your
inner dialogue,
you feel a sense
of ease and calm.
So if years down the
road, you remember nothing
else from this talk, except I
am not selling, I am serving--
every time you enter
those conversations,
you will have taken
away the golden nugget.
But we're going to continue.
Let's look at how
we can do this.
Let's make it more
practical and tangible.
To do that, you need to be
willing to set aside something
that you've been carrying
with yourself for a long time.
And that is your agenda.
We all have an agenda.
Whether your agenda is to get
promoted to that vice president
role, or to get a
yes on that contract,
or to bring on board
10 more clients--
you have an agenda.
Now, there's nothing
wrong with an agenda.
But when your mind
is on an agenda when
you are in a conversation
with your prospect,
it pulls you out of the present
moment with your prospect.
It is impossible to be
100% present with someone
and have your mind on an agenda.
Now, why do you want to
be 100% present with them?
Because that is the only way we
can form a genuine connection.
It's the only way you can truly
listen to what's being said,
and to hear someone.
And then to respond accordingly.
You cannot do that when
your mind is on an agenda
of your own.
But when you do that--
when you set aside your agenda--
you can create deep trust
in that slowing down and in
that listening place.
And so as you do
that, you are starting
to go into the serving mindset.
Let's make this practical.
I'll share with you an
example from one of my clients
who learned how to do this.
So my client, Patricia, runs a
successful IT consulting firm.
And she's very good
at what she does.
Now, as an introvert
and a techie,
she was feeling awkward,
tense, and uncomfortable
when she would step into her
prospecting conversations.
And so she came to me
because she hated selling.
So we started to work together.
And we gave her some tools and
techniques to overcome this.
Now as she learned how
to set aside her agenda--
which she hated anyway
because she hated selling,
but she felt she
had to have it--
she was suddenly more
comfortable in her own skin.
And as a result, she
was more confident.
And then, she was stepping
into those conversations
from that place.
And finally, she was
able to really hear
what her prospects were saying.
And really, really
listen and get
to the real challenges,
the real problems.
Not just the surface level ones.
As she did this over
time, something remarkable
started to happen.
Her prospects were now
leaning into Patricia
to ask her how they
could work with her.
How they could hire her
in a business capacity.
So she learned how to go
from selling to serving
by setting aside her agenda.
And she was creating real
business opportunities
as a result.
Now when you learn
to do that, you
find at the heart of the
serving mindset two things--
deep caring and deep
curiosity for your prospect,
regardless of outcome for you.
So when you do this, you start
to create that connection
we talked about.
You start to lay the
foundation of deep trust.
And not only that, you
do this because you
have a solution for them.
You have something that could
help with their problems.
But until you have gone deep
into those conversations,
you cannot know for a fact
whether your genius solution is
what they need.
And I think, it's safe to say
we've all been in a place--
especially as an engineer,
where I love to solve problems--
where someone comes to
you with their challenges,
and your intention
is to help them.
But you're not sure whether
your solution is right.
But you put it forth, and it's
not quite well-received yet.
We don't want to offer
our solution before we are
sure it's the real solution.
And you do that by going
deep into a conversation
with deep caring
and deep curiosity.
Now let's look at how this
would look in a corporate life
example.
I spent 12 years in
the corporate world.
And since then, I've
had the pleasure
of working with many
corporate professionals
from all walks of life.
When your average
corporate employee
reaches a certain level of
experience, qualifications,
and expertise, they want to
advance to that next level
and get promoted and
move up the ladder.
So when similar opportunities
present themselves
in their organizations,
they want to secure it.
So the next natural step
is having a conversation
with their manager.
Here is how those
conversations usually unfold.
The corporate employee
shares how much
they want that
promotion, how well
qualified they are for it, and
maybe, maybe that they even
deserve it.
They've worked really,
really hard to get here.
The manager agrees,
shows polite interest,
and might even
make some promises.
They have a great
conversation together,
and then absolutely
nothing happens.
It's very frustrating, because
the corporate employee is
wondering, what else
do I need to do,
how much harder
do I need to work.
And it's not about that.
It's about the value positioning
in that conversation.
So what the employee is
doing is justifying why
they are the best candidate.
They may very well be,
but that's their approach,
and that's not serving.
So let's see how this
conversation would be different
if they were to come to it
from a place of serving,
and deep caring,
and deep curiosity.
They would set aside their
agenda, which in this case
is to get promoted.
They would step into
that conversation
and be really curious
about their management's
real challenges, about
their real problems,
about the organization's
real goals and struggles,
and what a real solution
would look like.
So they would ask
different questions.
Some of those questions
might be, well, you know,
John or Janet--
please say your manager's name--
I've been doing
some research, and I
believe these are the three
top challenges in our project.
I would like to explore
those further with you.
Would you be open to that?
Or, here is what I see to be the
top challenge we have coming up
for the organization
in the coming year,
and I have some
ideas on how I can
be of value toward a solution.
Would you be open to
exploring that with me?
Now, this line of
questioning shows
that you are deeply
curious and you
care about your
management, your company.
You're not an individual
contributor now.
You are a leader.
You are having a different
conversation altogether,
and that welcomes a different
response from your manager.
Now, you may not get promoted
from this conversation
the next day, next month,
or even the next year.
But what happens is that
you change the perception
of your management on you.
They begin to see you
as value, as an asset
to the organization,
as a leader.
And I have seen this
shift in conversations
change people's careers,
the course of their careers,
and invite unexpected
opportunities.
So we use deep caring
and deep curiosity.
We set aside our agenda, and
we enter those conversations
from that place.
Now, I talked earlier
about how instinctively, we
all want to be of
genuine help and service.
Sometimes, we confuse
serving with pleasing.
So we're going to explore
that a little bit.
Pleasing is when you are
talking to your prospect.
And I use the word prospect--
I mean your prospective
employers, partners, customers,
clients, what have you.
And you feel you have to
agree to everything they say.
You have to be nice.
You tiptoe around
delicate topics.
You don't speak your mind
because it might upset them,
or it might not be
something they want to hear,
even though it
would benefit them.
So that's pleasing.
That is not the same as serving.
Remember, with serving, we have
our prospects' highest interest
at heart.
We need to be
willing to tell them
something that would
be of benefit to them,
even if it may not
be well received.
So the distinction between
pleasing and serving
is what I want to demonstrate
in my next example.
So one of my other
clients, Danielle,
is a scientist by training.
Very good at what
she does, again.
She recently got promoted to
the role of chief marketing
officer, CMO, at her company.
In this role, her job was
to form key partnerships
with other companies, and
she was having some struggle
doing this.
So as we worked together, we
saw that her real challenge
was she didn't feel comfortable
telling her prospects exactly
what she wanted to tell them.
She felt she had to please
them and agree with everything.
So as a result, she was having
surface level conversations,
and she wasn't getting
responses to her messages.
She wasn't getting invited
to other conversations.
Her relationships were
not moving further.
So as we worked together,
we gave her several tools
to overcome this.
One particular tool that
she was really able to use
was the art of
asking permissions.
So when she came to a
place in the conversation
where she felt, I really
need to go deeper,
but her personal
boundaries weren't making
her feel comfortable,
she would say,
would it be OK to ask you more
questions around this challenge
you shared with me?
Would you be comfortable with
us exploring that deeper?
That way she respected
her own boundaries,
but she stopped pleasing
and went deeper.
She did the work of serving.
As a result, she got way
more than she bargained for.
So not only were her prospects--
prospective partners-- more
than happy to tell her
their challenges at length,
she was able to move forward
in those relationships.
Why is that?
What did she do?
Danielle created this safe
space for her prospects
to feel comfortable
with her, to know
they wouldn't be judged if
they shared a particular fear
or something they were ashamed
of or their real challenges,
and they were able to be
vulnerable as a result.
So she was able to
lay the foundation
of real relationships.
She was able to get to the real
challenges of her prospects
and offer her solutions
if she saw fit.
So Danielle went from
pleasing to serving.
So in this first
guiding principle--
I am not selling, I am serving--
we saw how you go from
selling to serving,
how you go from
justifying why you're
the best candidate to
serving, and how you
go from pleasing to serving.
Right.
Let's talk about the
second guiding principle
of the serving mindset, and
that is charging appropriately
for the value that you deliver.
So the value you
deliver could be you
as a genius asset in your
organization in a company,
or it could be a professional
service that you deliver.
Charging appropriately
for that value.
Again, in my research, I
found smart, talented, highly
educated professionals
and entrepreneurs
like us tend to bet
very low on ourselves.
We think our value
is really small.
Why is that?
Well, it came to three main
reasons, and all of them
fall under the umbrella
of negative thinking.
The first reason--
scarcity mindset.
There simply isn't enough
opportunities out there for me,
so I have to grab
whatever comes my way.
So if you're in a job
interview process,
you feel, I have to say
yes to this job because it
could be the last one.
If you are prospecting
clients, you
feel you have to close the
one before you because it
could be the last one.
There simply isn't enough
opportunities out there for me.
Excuse me.
I did this early in
my coaching practice.
I priced my professional
coaching services
so low because I had to attract
all those few opportunities out
there.
Well, as a result, I attracted
the most unfit clients.
Not only were they not
the right fit for me,
I certainly wasn't the
right fit for them.
Nobody was served
well in this scenario.
Scarcity mindset-- number one
reason we bet low on ourselves.
The second reason we
bet low on ourselves
is lack of worthiness, or rather
confusion around worthiness.
We just don't think
we're worth it.
We don't think we are
worth the high salary
we should be asking,
or the high prices
we should be charging
for our services.
Now, I found with worthiness
we tend to confuse it
with arrogance and greed.
We tend to think we would come
across as arrogant and greed,
and who wants that?
None of us.
So we keep it safe.
I'll give you an example here
to see how this worthiness
issue can be a
complete deterrent
of your opportunities.
So I have a friend who is
a professional speaker.
He's brilliant, and he
really has a good message.
He wanted to secure
this particular event
because he felt his message
would be of great value
to his audience.
Well, he also didn't
think he could possibly
be worth more than
$1,500, so that's
what he quoted for
his speaking fee.
The organizers came back to
him and said, we're sorry,
but we don't put anyone
up on that stage who
charges less than $5,000.
Now, the speaker not only
disqualified himself,
he robbed his would be
audience of his great message.
Worthiness did not serve
anyone in this equation.
The third reason we tend
to bet low on ourselves
is because we don't
think they'll say yes.
We think people will say no.
And so we make sure we keep
it really, really safe.
Now, in eight years of being
in business and being a coach
and having worked with people
from all walks of life,
I can tell you, every
time I try to guess
who is willing to invest what--
every single time--
I was wrong.
And not only that, it's none
of my business to guess.
My business is to serve
and to charge appropriately
for the value that I deliver.
So some reasons why we
bet low on ourselves.
But no matter what
your reasons, here
is the real kicker when
you have low prices.
Low prices associate you
with low quality of work.
We established you are
no longer a beginner.
You are a professional.
You have years of
experience, expertise,
and qualifications behind you.
When you charge low
prices for your value,
you send a very confusing
message to your target market.
Your ideal prospect knows
the value of your work.
They know what they are
willing to invest in you.
Your low prices confuse
them, and they associate you
with low quality of work,
which is not fair to you,
and it certainly isn't the
right message to send out.
So now that we are sufficiently
motivated to charge
appropriately,
yes, let's see how
we can turn this around
and bring you back
to the serving mindset.
We're going to use our power
to choose our thoughts here.
Number one-- the
abundance mindset,
which I'm sure you've guessed,
says there is more than enough
opportunities out there for me--
more than I can imagine.
Now, I know it's easy
enough for me to stand here
and say, OK, choose
the abundance mindset
over scarcity.
But I will give you a
really good reason for it.
Just as you cannot prove
to me this is the last job
that's coming your way, this
is the last prospective client,
you also cannot prove
there aren't 100 more great
opportunities out there.
Can't prove either one.
So why not choose the
more empowering thought?
Because the minute you do that,
you feel a surge of confidence.
Imagine going into
your conversations
from a place of confidence
instead of a place of neediness
or desperation.
You will have different results.
The second reason we're
going to bring you back
to the serving mindset is
to clear up this whole issue
around worthiness.
Your worth does not
fluctuate with your prices.
Your worth has nothing
to do with your prices.
It is who you are as a person.
It is your character.
It is how you live your life.
So what we need to do
is separate worthiness
from the equation.
When you learn to
do that, you can
think rationally and
logically about the value
that you deliver and charge
appropriately for it.
So three ways we can bring you
back to charging appropriately
for it because when you charge
appropriately for the value
you deliver, you are serving
yourself and your prospects.
Low prices can hurt you.
We need to charge appropriately.
Now, this dovetails nicely into
our third guiding principle--
welcoming and
addressing objections.
This is my favorite,
and this is one
that takes a bit of
courage, but nothing
that we can't muster here.
First, I'd like to
define objection.
An objection is-- let's say
I've had a great conversation
with my prospect, John, and
he says to me, Farnoosh,
you're great.
Love to have you.
You're the best.
We'd love to hire you, but--
everything that follows
the but is an objection
in my prospect's mind.
It's the gap between where
we are right now together
and a resounding yes.
We may or may not get there.
Now, what happens when we
normally receive an objection?
We feel a sense of rejection.
It's normal.
Somebody just said no.
Especially if it's preceded
by a bunch of compliments.
It hurts.
And after the rejection,
what is our next response?
We tend to go into a
bit of justification
and self-defense mode.
Let me tell you why you
really should hire me.
No, this is not
what you understood.
This is why I can really be of
value, et cetera, et cetera.
That thinking pulls you away
from the serving mindset
because now you're
focused on yourself.
Now, before we go back
to the serving mindset,
I'll give you a really good
reason around rejection
even though I totally get it.
It's not nice to feel rejected.
But here is why it's
impossible to be rejected.
Remember, we are
no longer selling.
If you're with me, we
are no longer selling.
We're only serving.
So if you're not
selling anything,
what are you being rejected for?
You simply put an
offer on the table,
and you received a response.
So if it's impossible
to be rejected,
there is no need to go into
the justification mode.
Now, how do we come
to the objections
from a place of serving?
Well, first we need to be
able to welcome, receive,
and explore the objections.
We may or may not
overcome every objection.
Overcoming means that
is no longer an issue
on our prospect's mind.
But sometimes your prospect
gives you great information.
It may make you think,
oh, you know what?
Maybe it's not a good
idea to engage right now.
Maybe it's not a
good idea for me
to come on board at this time.
So we cannot always
overcome the objection,
but our job is to explore them.
Why do we do this?
Because we want to get
to the real objection.
So the first reason
your prospect
gives you is not always the
real reason they are saying no.
To get to that real
reason, you need
to have a deep level of
trust in that relationship.
And our job is to get
to the real reason
because the real reason helps
us decide if we are indeed
the right solution for them.
So when you have your prospect's
highest interests at heart,
and you are helping them arrive
at a smart decision for them,
you learn to welcome
and address objections
so that we can get to
the real objection.
And then we can see whether
we can overcome it together.
Let me go back to my
example with John.
Let's say he says to me,
Farnoosh, you're great.
We'd love to hire you, but we
don't have the budget for it.
The world's oldest excuse
around business propositions.
And I call it an excuse
because sometimes it's
the real objection--
often, it is not.
Now, how would I
respond to John here?
I would say, first, John, thank
you for sharing that with me.
I thank him.
Would it be OK if I ask you
more questions around that?
I ask permission
before I probe further.
Now, I've never had anyone
say, no, you may not
ask me any more questions.
It may yet happen, but let's
assume he says, yes, go ahead.
And then I would say,
John, I am curious.
What budget did you have in
mind relative to the value
I would be delivering?
Remember, we just learned
to charge appropriately
for the value we deliver.
A budget doesn't
exist in a vacuum.
It needs to be relative
to the value you
deliver to the organization
or to the project.
Now, John may still
shrug off the example.
He may still not answer me.
We have a fixed budget.
I don't know.
My job is to stay grounded in
who I am, to know my value--
so don't go into
discounting mode.
In fact, don't even
talk about the budget.
Go back to discussing value.
I might say to John, you
know, John, I'm curious.
How do you see the value I
would be adding to the project?
What is your vision of
us working together?
How do you see me helping you
towards your desired outcomes--
your desired results?
You go back to making sure
your prospect understands
the value that you are going
to bring to their work,
to their business,
to their careers.
Now, again, I may not
get a straight answer,
but what you are doing
is creating space
for your prospect
to confide in you.
Very few are willing to go here.
Your ego mind is telling
you I don't like this.
This is uncomfortable.
Get me out of here.
Don't listen.
Stay present.
Create space for your prospect
to be honest with you,
to tell you the real
reasons they may not
be able to hire you right
now, to work with you.
And then help them arrive
at the best decision based
on that information.
Now, those are the
occasions when your prospect
is nice enough to tell
you why they don't
want to work with you just yet.
Sometimes we get a
different response.
I'm willing to bet
we've all had this one.
You've had a great conversation.
You feel like everything
went really, really well.
And then they say, so Farnoosh,
we'd love to hire you,
love to work with you.
We're going to think about
it and get back to you.
And then I hear nothing.
They just disappear.
And I'm feeling,
should I follow up?
That whole awkward follow
up after a conversation
because we don't know
what really happened.
We weren't clear.
So that's when your
prospect obviously
had an objection because we're
not sitting on a yes here,
but they didn't feel
comfortable sharing it with you.
So again, if you go back to
deep trust and deep caring
and explore that, you might
just get them to share.
Something you might say
would be, you know, Janet,
I think we've had a
great conversation, too.
I totally respect that you
have to go and think about it.
Tell me, are there any
concerns right now on your mind
that I can address for you?
Might you have any questions
as to what I would be doing,
how we would be
working together,
as you make your decision?
They may or may not still
give you the real objection,
but again, you've created space.
You have shown your prospect
you truly care about them
and you are there to help
them make a decision that's
right for them.
So this does require courage
because, like I said,
your ego mind wants you to run.
But if you stay with it,
this is a golden opportunity.
If you learn the
skill of navigating
this part of the conversation,
and create space and trust,
you will see that you
are laying the foundation
for a different kind of
relationship altogether.
So we explored three
guiding principles
of the serving mindset--
stop selling, start serving,
charge appropriately
for the value that you
deliver, and welcome
and address objections.
Now, I know as
professionals that you
know how to have conversations.
You've been doing
it for some time.
You know how to go into a
conversation and ask questions,
and I'm sure you do.
But I believe the
only opinion that
matters when we are having
prospecting conversations
is that of our prospect.
So to that end, might you be
willing to take a mental quiz
together?
You don't need a pen and paper.
All right.
Good.
I'm getting nods.
So bring to mind your
warmest prospect--
your prospective employer,
partner, customer.
Somebody with whom you've
been having conversations,
you have been doing
due diligence,
you feel as if you have a
good relationship going,
and you're working
toward a decision.
Now, if I were to call your
prospect anonymously and ask
them on a scale of 1 to 10--
where 1 is poor and
10 is excellent--
what rating might they give
you on how well you understand
their real challenge?
Their real fears
and frustrations?
Their real goals as it
relates to your context?
What rating might they give you?
If it's less than
a nine, you don't
have to share it with
anyone, but there
is room for you to go deeper
in that beautiful relationship
you're building.
This is a golden opportunity
to deepen that trust
and to see that you can, indeed,
change the course of outcomes
of those conversations.
So my challenge to
you is next time
you have a prospecting
conversation
to set aside your agenda--
no agenda-- to go into it
from a place of deep caring
and deep curiosity,
regardless of outcome for you,
and to see what happens,
to see what experience
unfolds for both of you.
I think you might be
pleasantly surprised.
So as you think about this
and bring the serving mindset
into your
conversations, you will
find that you are developing
a deeper level of relationship
altogether, that
you are creating
different results for yourself,
and that in the process,
you are feeling joy and
fulfillment in the work.
I hope I've given you
some good insights today,
and now we can go into
a Q&A if you like.
AUDIENCE: And I
really love your story
of how you went from
the corporate world
to kind of creating your
own profitable business
in the past 18 months.
It's really amazing.
So for me, I actually run my
own kind of career consulting.
It's called [INAUDIBLE],, and
I do these workshops and kind
of webinars for students
on the university level.
And so this year I've actually
done about 16 of them,
so it's been a really
good experience,
but I struggle with kind of--
only one has been paid,
so most of them are free.
So it's really fun to do.
It's really fun to
bring value to people.
But for me, I kind of struggle
to find a price point,
or find a price point
for the value I bring.
So my question
would be, how do you
go from basically
free prospects,
or doing these free
workshops, to paid workshops?
And then also, when
do you know when
it's time to leave
the corporate world
and then go pursue
entrepreneurship?
FARNOOSH BROCK: OK.
So great questions.
Thank you, Jonathan.
So I would say the pricing.
The pricing really,
again, comes down
to the value you're delivering.
You've been doing this
work for free-- great.
You have already experienced
and you have created--
I trust-- results
for your clients.
Look at those results.
Look at the impact you had
creating those results,
whether it was
tangible or intangible.
So tangible is when you
helped somebody get a raise
and it's measurable
in dollars and cents.
Intangible is when you help
someone have more confidence,
have more courage, make
a difficult transition
in their lives.
Both of those are value that
you have helped deliver.
And then look at that--
and there is different
ways to go about this.
I mean, when you don't
have any baseline,
you can just start somewhere.
I know it sounds
random, and it's not,
but you start somewhere.
The range for coaching
services is from $50 an hour
to $1 million a year,
some coaches charge for.
It's a large range, right?
So you start somewhere.
And I think questions
I like to ask
myself is, when I get paid for
this amount, is this worth it?
Is this worth the energy
and time on my part,
or will I be resentful
for putting all this
and feeling like I'm not
getting enough, you know?
And I think that's personal
for all of us-- that number.
And then, another
thing you can do,
since you've already done
due diligence for people,
is go to your past customers--
and you've done it
for free for them,
so maybe they can
owe you a favor--
and say, look, I'm
wondering, what would you
have paid for the
value I delivered
to you-- for the work we did?
So get some numbers
and see whether you
can get some ideas as
to what was the value
and what is it that people are
willing to pay-- especially
in hindsight because now they
see the value in their lives,
in their education,
in their careers.
And think about how
that might give you
an idea of where to start.
And then from there,
I think, again,
look at the energy you put
in, the time you put in,
the differences that you make.
And, of course, with
experience, your impact grows,
and so your prices should be
adapting to that over time,
naturally.
And your second
question was, gosh,
when do you know that it's time
to leave the corporate world?
And I think that's a very
personal one for all of us,
and it really comes down
to your values, you know.
If you value a
sense of happiness,
joy, wellness,
health, and if you
feel like you're sacrificing
that by keeping your job,
or the culture at
the workplace doesn't
align to your personal values--
family could be a big value.
At some point, we
reach a tipping point
where we just don't
want to continue
because it's not worth it.
Life is short.
We want to have a sense of
alignment to our values,
so we enjoy life.
And so that tipping point
came for me at a certain time.
It came for my clients
at different times.
And I think also
being responsible
around that decision,
right, because we still
have responsibilities.
We still have bills to pay.
And how to plan around that
and maybe adapt our lifestyle
so we create a cushion so
that we allow the next thing
we're going to do-- our business
to flourish, to catch up.
So if I were to give
you a short answer,
it comes down to values--
what really matters to you.
And if you feel, at
the end of the day,
your corporate job
allows you to do
that, or with some shifts,
some changes and priorities,
you can still do that,
then maybe you're not
at a place to quit your job.
And in some places, some
locations, you might be.
I hope I'm not giving
you vague answers.
These are big topics,
so hopefully giving you
some insights to think over.
Thank you for your question.
Yeah, you bet.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned you come
and maybe you've got
a prospect that you're
going to be speaking to.
Do you have a ritual or anything
that you say or visualize
prior to that and that
you're able to really connect
in that way?
Curious what works for you.
FARNOOSH BROCK: Yeah,
not so much that,
but what I like to do is--
I mean, over time, I
think more than anything
is knowing that I
am good at what I
do if it's the right prospect.
Knowing the value you deliver.
Being really grounded in that.
So having clarity around what
you do and what you do well,
and then going into
that conversation
and being open to learn.
So I don't have a ritual
before, but coming
to this place of
being really grounded,
really knowing what
am I about, what
is my sweet spot, how
I can help people,
and knowing that I can--
and it helps to have those past
clients, like Jonathan has,
to show that, look, there
is actual experience here.
And keeping that in mind.
But also being open
to explore and, again,
seeing whether there is a fit.
And it always helps to maybe
have some quiet time before,
to learn more about
the person, and to have
a framework for the
conversation so you
are leading that conversation
even as they are sharing,
exploring with you.
I think that's maybe helpful.
And you know where it's going
because they are inquiring
of your services, and you
are kind of leading that
to where you want it to go.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I have a question regarding
sort of the genesis of this.
So typically, when we talk
about sales and influence
discussions, a lot
of the emphasis
is on techniques,
frameworks, scripts.
But I think what's
interesting about what
you've shared with us is
that it is about the mindset.
And I'm just kind of curious
as to how you discovered
that mindset is what
unlocked the greater
success in those conversations?
FARNOOSH BROCK:
Sure, great question.
Yes, I mean, to give you more
context, the first few years
in my business, I did all the
traditional selling techniques.
And I had moderate success.
It didn't feel good.
Like, this strategy,
and this question,
and this scarcity mindset,
and this manipulation.
I did them, just to experiment,
and I had moderate success,
but it didn't feel good.
And so then I started
to just, again,
get more confident
in what I was doing
and the results
I was delivering.
And then I just
started to go down
to the human touch,
the human dynamics.
I mean, I don't have
a complicated system.
I have a methodology
around the serving,
but it is really about
how you make someone
feel heard and understood.
It really is about being of
genuine help and service,
and then knowing your own value
if there is an opportunity
for us to work together.
So I might have one conversation
with one person, another
with another.
I take into account their
personalities, their styles,
because for me, the
most important thing
is to connect with
the individual
because we do business--
we don't do business
with faceless companies.
We do business with people.
Even if you are a B2B, you
do business with people.
And so it's all about
connecting with people.
It's not about
manipulating them.
It's about building a deep
relationship through trust,
through listening,
through slowing down,
through setting
aside our agenda,
but still knowing that
we have goals to achieve.
And if this is the
right fit, we are
going to put a nice
proposal on the table.
And really comes down
to the relationships.
So again, how did I discover it?
Experimentation.
Tons of conversations with
many different people--
people who would come to me--
and learning from
people that I respect.
Watching people
have conversations
and seeing what
resonates with me, right,
because it has to
resonate with you.
You can't fake it.
So whatever you take away has
to be something you really want
to embody in that conversation.
And I think experience
is the best lesson.
So you take what I
shared here with you,
you bring it to a
conversation, and you
have firsthand experience,
whether that works better
for you or not.
Thank you.
Great.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.